Speaker 1: Welcome back to The David Pakman
Show, I am Ferren cousins from Ring of Fire,
sitting in for David Pakman today.
And if you happen to enjoy me here, you can
catch me on the Ring of Fire YouTube channel,
YouTube Dotcom, The Ring of Fire.
You can also find me on my YouTube channel,
YouTube, dotcom, fair and balanced.
Of course, I'm all over all social media outlets
Facebook, Twitter, Instagram at and balanced.
Now, let's talk about covid for a minute.
Right.
Obviously, biggest story happening in the
country right now, especially as we have children
heading back to school within the next few
weeks.
Florida, where I am right now, 20 percent
of nationwide covid cases coming from this
state.
Our kids go back to school today.
And we still don't have statewide mask mandates
because our governor, Rhonda Santurce, actually
signed a ban on mask mandates, it was an executive
order, to be perfectly honest.
And the Republican controlled legislature,
by the way, a long time ago during the pandemic,
actually gave him the authority to do that.
Now, as I mentioned on this program on Friday,
some counties have defied Santurce order dissatisfies
order.
And so over the weekend, though, you had Republican
Senator Bill Cassidy from the state of Louisiana
actually come out on CNN, State of the Union
and take a couple shots at Rhonda Santos for
banning mask mandates for children in school.
Here's what Cassidy said.
I'm a conservative.
I think you govern best when you govern closest
to the people being governed.
And if a local community is having a their
ICU is full and the people at the local schools
see that they've got to make sure they stay
open because otherwise children miss out on
for another year of school and they put in
policy than the local officials should be
listened to.
Now, he kind of didn't say that as clearly
as possible.
He was asked about the mask mandates because
we have one here in Florida.
They got one in Texas, two of the worst states
in the country with covid.
And that was his response.
Like, you got to let the local officials make
those decisions.
Not every county here in the state of Florida
is as bad as the one next to it now, it's
bad all over the state.
Don't get me wrong.
But this should be the decision, excuse me,
up to the local officials here, but the Santos
took away.
Cities and counties, right to make that decision
for themselves, and that is what Cassity is
actually taking a swipe at here.
We've seen it happen in Arkansas, we're seeing
it happen in Texas, where the actual authority
is being stripped from local communities and
instead given to one person at the top of
that food chain, Florida.
It's De Santos, Arkansas, who now says he
regrets it is Hutchinson, Texas.
It's Abbott.
Meanwhile, Louisiana, who is also seeing a
massive spike in go, but they're going back
to mask mandates.
It's a red state.
But they have enough good sense to say, listen,
things are bad, and so we have to go back
to this.
If people aren't going to voluntarily protect
themselves, we're going to have to put the
law in place.
The rule in place that says you have to protect
yourself because it's not just you, it's literally
everybody else around you.
And that's when it changes from being about
personal choice, as too many Republicans want
to say.
To a public policy health issue, and that
is something that can be governed, that is
something that can be legislated if it is
a public health concern, what you and your
individual choices are, then, yeah, that can
be regulated.
People love to use the example of drunk driving,
and that really is a great example if you
want to sit on your couch.
And drink a handle of vodka and then just
pass out for the night.
That's your personal choice.
OK, and as long as you're of age, nobody can
stop you from doing that.
However, if you want to drink that same amount
of alcohol, then get behind the wheel of a
vehicle, then, yeah, suddenly that's a public
health concern.
And we do have laws against that because at
that point, you put other people in danger.
It's the same with not wearing masks, maybe
not to such an extreme extent, but we do have
a virus that is still mutating, that is still
spreading, that is highly transmissible, transmissible.
The Delta variant is much more likely to make
children sick than covid original.
And this is what we're dealing with right
now.
So while I may not agree with him on quite
possibly anything else, I do applaud Senator
Cassidy for taking the time and responding
to the question correctly.
He could have been a little more overt about
it, but I'm not going to deny him for that.
This should be a decision that's up to each
individual school board after hearing from
parents, after listening to medical professionals,
because we've seen far too many videos, by
the way, of angry, deranged anti VAX parents
saying we don't need vaccines, we don't need
masks.
You can probably ignore those people, maybe
have the school board just meet with doctors
or maybe have them go visit the hospitals
in states like Florida and Texas that are
currently filling up.
And then they should be the ones to make the
decision on whether mask mandates go into
place.
And another another good
point about that.